Russia is targeting Ukraine's energy
infrastructure with deliberate strikes
we are working with Ukraine to restore
electricity supplies by repairing and
restoring the damaged infrastructure
and by developing and deploying
renewable energy
one month ago
I announced an initiative to deliver
solar panels to Ukraine
now I can announce that the first batch
of solar panels will be delivered to
Ukraine soon
NL is donating
5700 solar panels for Ukraine
solar panels produced in Europe in
Catania with the support of the European
Innovation fund
these panels can cover more than 11
000 square meters of roofs of public
buildings so they will provide
electricity to schools to hospitals to
fire departments
I am convinced that other European
companies as well as member states will
be inspired by this first step
so that Ukraine can rely on clean
electricity
produced at home